question ce qu'il ya des moments où les
pays ont besoin d'un bol d'air frais et
un moment où on est tellement au bout de
deux de la lassitude de de l'
exaspération à l'égard de blocage de
système qui marche plus qu' il ya des
moments où les pays se tourne vers une
vision nouvelle vers un regard nouveau
une recomposition et pas seulement vers
est un homme nouveau une personnalité un
homme nouvelles jeunes et qui en effet à
est sortie du cadre qu'on voulait lui
tracé est en tout cas pour moi qui
attend ce moment depuis tellement
longtemps
je considère que c'est un moment clé de
l'histoire conte est que vraiment vous
avez fait la fête